you told me once that you would consider
and not many people have said this you
would consider
hosting a talk show i would love that
and i think you'd be uh quite i would
good at it you're very funny you're very
verbal you're quick i think you'd be
terrific i appreciate that i would be no
conan i know that you're you're very
you know you get some twits coming
through a talk show panel right and
you're always so d is he not always
decent to people never makes them feel
bad
[Applause]
yeah he's that way on camera
you'll pay richton
no yeah go ahead go ahead um
i mean that's that's just about it i
don't think that i would be as decent to
someone who is just twatting on about
the most inane garbage uh i would i
don't know what i i would i'd have to
out them on i wouldn't be able to
pretend
that what you're thinking and feeling
and what i'm thinking and feeling is not
going on i would want to like hit an
ejector button or something like that
right like if this thing had springs
that would be exciting would it not i
mean if you could push a button and the
boring guest or the self-involved guest
is shot through the air
into the ceiling and killed no one needs
to get killed i think it's a better show
i don't think
they're killed eight feet up and they
drop and they're hurt yeah they're hurt
and then we bring out the next guest and
they're just writhing and yeah yeah
keep it down they can go up into some
sort of a spike pad and then through the
second guest you just get you get a drop
a drop of blood every few wow
that's great but like wouldn't it be
great if like you guys had like a little
panel out there and the the aggregate
score would dictate
along with the host the host has uh a
majority of of of the voting thank you
that's good at some power being able to
see though guess would not be able to be
like a little gage behind them if you
get towards the danger if you just suck
you get you get the zots and and now you
got like the gong show yeah well see
that would be i think it's a fascinating
show and someone's probably doing that
or developing it right now it's like an
adult swim kind of thing you know i
think when we go mainstream i think
you've got to think bigger
and let's do this that's my problem
let's do this okay let's do this what
about what would you do let's say you
really were in my position and you were
talking to someone and
they were just droning on about but the
director really pushed me and i think
it's my best work my director i love
when they say my director and my cast oh
my cast it's not yours it's not yours
yeah yeah we were like a family yeah oh
yeah yeah you were people that spent
some time together you don't yeah you
know hey settle down richard i'm sorry
so what kind of look because you have a
great
you have a great deadpan you have great
your eyes can just leave you dead like
sharks they go dead like a shark size
do you have this so this would be
pre-button yeah before the button i
think it would be great if they took a
shot of your face is the boy
yeah and i'm talking i'm the guest and
i'm just going oh no now
[Applause]
that was fantastic that was a great that
look would make that would make the show
and then you'd see that soon after that
they'd be shot up into the ceiling
into the spike pad in the spike pattern
and q q the blood rain exactly